hear the music cue the feeling the NCAA
tournament round of 16 is underway this
weekend's action has college teams from
around the country competing in four
different cities to be one step closer
to being champions of the NCAA
tournament Vlad no but we thought it
would be a good idea to give our Super
Bowl cities tradition a makeover for the
sweet 16. we are giving you a close look
at those four cities hosting this
weekend's action and we Enlisted the
help of our local CBS stations and
Affiliates who know their sweet cities
better than anyone else
welcome to the Big Apple
people come to New York City from all
over the world to fulfill their dreams
and reach New Heights and in this case
literally we're at Edge the highest
observatory in the Western Hemisphere
[Music]
you can always try City climb you can
actually see Madison Square Garden
behind me the host of this weekend's
games but for now folks just let me
enjoy a whole different type of Madness
ah
hate to break into your desk but you'll
need to scale skyscrapers to find grills
here in Vegas you know we're just the
entertainment capital of the world
foreign
to catch the game on this 40-foot screen
here at Stadium swim
[Music]
the girls are what you seek here you can
not only play the slot machines but
zipline
[Music]
hey Candace let's not forget about
Louisville and yes it's pronounced
Louisville where we have much more than
just miniature horses
we're known as the Derby City home of
the Kentucky Derby which you can
win one of these the official drink of
the race the Woodford Reserve classic
mint Jeweler
while your zip lines may take you above
the city ours is the only one in the
world entirely underground and these
Limestone Caverns beneath the city here
we go
whoa whoa whoa whoa are we talking zip
lines or basketball definitely
basketball and Kansas City is the
birthplace of college basketball Dr
James naysmith the inventor of
basketball started with the NAIA then
brought the sport to the University of
Kansas as its first coach and nine final
fours have been played right here more
than any other facility
and by the way Alex those Caverns are
nothing compared to this 55 million
square foot Cavern below the streets of
Kansas City it's the world's largest
underground business complex you can't
even get signal down here Doug you there
yeah I hear you Carolina and I can't
complain about the service that this New
York City Hidden Gem
buying this phone booth is please don't
tell Speakeasy where you can grab
delicious cocktails thank you Jeff
as well as classic New York City hot
dogs I mean what is not to love about
that okay Doug I'll match your hot dog
with something a little more creative
like this famous Louisville delicacy the
hot brown this open-faced turkey
sandwich is made with two kinds of
cheese and bacon it was invented right
here at the brown Hotel
or you can try a cheese slipper
a Kansas City specialty so popular this
Bakery runs out anytime they're on the
menu
here in Vegas grab a booth at this
legendary Eatery the Golden Steer a
favorite hangout for Elvis and The Rat
Pack
and nowadays Garth Brooks sting Katy
Perry and Usher are just a few of the
legendary names taking a presidency here
on Las Vegas Strip Stars come on the
greatest boxer of all time was born in
Louisville the TKO decision for Cassius
Clay and while we're talking Sports the
famous Louisville Slugger baseball bat
was created right here and thousands are
made every single day including this
special one just for CBS mornings all
right Alex but Casey has the Ultimate
Sports bragging right that's right as
you may recall we just won the Super
Bowl
you already know we have massive
skyscrapers here in New York but we also
have this colossal Leading Lady the
Statue of Liberty
well we have our own tablet live views
that you can check out right here at one
of the world's largest observation rules
and speaking of Wheels we've got this
epic roller rink if you want to enjoy a
little throwback
[Music]
I'm pretty sure that roller skating is
much better under a disco ball this
Louisville company helped Usher in the
Disco era as the largest producer of
disco balls in the country
okay guys let's bring it back to the
ball that matters here at velocity
Esports you can test your skills stress
free what you got Alex thanks Candace
but here at the Yum Center tonight teams
will square off in front of a packed
crowd and not only do we have one of the
best college rivalries with the
Louisville Cardinals and the Kentucky
Wildcats but our viewers watch March
Madness and record numbers every year
top that Doug well easily Alex because
some of the best basketball players of
all time are from New York City this is
the mecca of streetfall in the United
States what about you guys though in KC
Bill and Carolina
how do you like them apples hi guys it's
cheetahcraft from Houston over here okay
okay so you may have zip lines
skyscrapers burgers and disco balls you
know we have a lot of that here in
Houston too but the one thing that no
other city has that only we have here in
H-Town
the final four and the national
championship that's right the road to
the final four ends here
well do we have a verdict what is the
greatest city of the final four cities
well I'm biased because I worked there I
would say Kansas New York I was born in
New York City I was born right here I
got to put New York aside and I love
Vegas one of my favorite cities but
Louisville is a great town so I'm gonna
go Louisville awesome
don't you just say they're all very good
they all bring something and that they
all brings something amazing guys I mean
what our colleagues did in those cities
and I I learned a lot I didn't know half
the things that they showed us in that
piece really cool nicely done nicely
done all right coverage of the NCAA
Men's Basketball sweet 16 continues
tonight on CBS and TBS